Film Courage: Adam do you outline every story
that you write?
Adam Skelter, writer, director, story artist:
Yeah…I’m pretty thorough with outlining.
I’ll spend quite a bit of time outlining
before I even write the full…like I’ll
usually have a complete full outline and then
jump into the story.
So I’ll have a really specific idea of the
objective of every single scene and ultimately
it saves me time.
When I first started writing I was anti-outline.
I kind of had the attitude, you know the young
attitude I’m just going to write and my
gut’s going to tell me what’s right and
what’s meaningful and stuff like that and
that works for a lot of writers.
But I noticed I hit a lot of dead ends and
I became emotionally attached to those dead
ends and then it became very hard to rewrite
and then it drove my stories off the cliff.
And so little by little, honestly that Ron
Mita 24-plot-point-thing was huge because
it was so simple.
You could literally just sit there and plot
out a story in an hour and you could have
a really good idea about where it was going.
And then from there…for me that’s where
you go from like discovery your story to actually
becoming a craftsman (or craftsperson) where
you are working on the story and start to
take control of it and you take a step back.
It’s almost like a render machine, you’re
rendering your story before you ever sit down
and write it.
So then the script really just becomes kind
of like secondary artifact of all the work
you’ve put into it.
So yeah, I spend a lot of time outlining.
And it’s…a lot of people thinks that it
takes away from the creative process.
Usually that’s kind of the writer saying
“Well, I want to be in the audience, too.
And I want to experience and be surprised
by it.”
But outlining doesn’t take away from that
because when you sit down you’ve outlined,
you’ve got your outline right here.
And then when you’re writing, you put yourself
in the moment, you’re in the skin of the
writer or the character.
And you are experiencing it and then if your
gut tells you try something different, try
something different, see where it goes.
So you are still…you know…gardener versus
architect, passer versus plotter kind of thing.
I call it The Assassins versus The Berserkers.
Basically the planner versus the person who
just sees what happens next.
And I think it’s important to understand
the consequences of the choices you’re making.
But the whole process of writing is an experiment,
art is an experiment.
The only thing that rules it is do we make
it emotionally resonate for somebody else.
And as artists we get to decide how much that
is.
How we build that relationship.
If.
We want to do it for a living than we become
responsible to those people who are investing
in us and that’s when you want to be able
to have control of your craft.
That’s when you want to be able to climb
the mountain, know how you’re going to get
up there, meet a deadline.
There aren’t a lot of producers that are
going to be like “Alright, we needed this
three months ago.”
And you are still just kind of like wandering
in the weeds.
But a lot of the process of writing is just
experimenting into the weeds, going into the
weeds and then stepping back.
And the trick is just not panicking when you’re
in the weeds and saying “Okay, this is part
of the process.
Let’s step back and look at the outline
and see if it’s going to work.”
So for me it feels like a map, it feels like
you’re zooming in.
And you can do the street view where you are
in the character and you’re driving along
and you’re like “Yeah, I feel this, I’m
going through this street.”
And that’s when you’re writing.
But then you pull back, you zoom out and you
see the overview of where you’re going and
that’s the outline.
Film Courage: So do you think without an outline
a writer back themselves into a corner a little
bit?
Adam Skelter: I mean we’re all vulnerable
to that, even with an outline we’re vulnerable
to that.
But again, I don’t believe in any right
or wrong
There is this one writer Bob Sáenz.
He’s amazing, he says he doesn’t outline,
he’s successful, he writes great stuff.
He just wrote Extracurricular and it’s fantastic.
I read the script and it’s so good.
And he doesn’t outline but he knows how
to write.
He gets to where he needs to go and he knows
how to tell a story.
So it’s like what works for you is fine.
The important thing is to be able to sell
it to the producers, to engage the people
that need to be engaged.
You are writing for readers largely.
So you want to learn the language of what
they expect.
But within that, it’s whatever gets you
there.
I don’t think you have any obligation but
generally speaking the average person would
benefit from taking the time to plan where
their story is going to go, have a good idea
of where it’s going to end and work toward
that.
Film Courage: In the past have you introduced
that 24-plot-point system to some of your
students and were they surprised?
Adam Skelter: Yeah, in my first video [on
Adam’s Youtube channel THE ART OF STORY]
I introduce the 24-plot-points and then I
break it down into acts, and then sequences
and then scenes and then everything like that.
So it’s like a really simple…a lot of
people they will stare at the blank page.
I’ve never understood staring at the blank
page.
Because by the time I’m ready to write a
scene, I’ve already had pages of writing.
It’s like the slingshot, you are just like
slowly preparing, getting all of the scenes,
getting the character, getting the plot, the
conflict, you know what every character wants.
So when you sit down and are ready to write,
you let go and you’re just flying.
But it really comes down to everybody discovering
their own process and I’m not a purist.
And a lot of people don’t outline and they
are very good writers, they are very successful.
A lot of that is the intuition or their experience
that informs it.